hello rich and adam this is casey from
illinois and i am running
chicago marathon for the first time in
october and i was wondering if you've
had
any uh like after race after run
uh tips and uh thank you for all you do
love the practice lookbooks thank you
thanks casey did he say after race
after run you know i thought it was just
any race than
after run tips but let's let's just go
with what you got
um right because i saw this typed out
before
i listened to it and now i'm wondering
whether i need to rethink this but
i'm going to answer it the way that i
feel like answering it there you go this
is helpful to casey
first of all with respect to race tips
there's this maxim that you shouldn't do
anything on race day that you didn't do
in training
race day is not the time to test out a
fancy new pair of shoes or a new pacing
strategy or some kind of
new nutrition protocol or some gel that
you've never tried before
training is all about testing testing
testing so that by the time you
you reach a race you already know
exactly what you're doing the race is
merely the execution of what you've
already done
so if you've trained properly and you
visualized it
then it just becomes about showing up
enjoying yourself
and celebrating the journey that got you
there so having fun
enjoying it i think is super important
the whole idea
of running a marathon is to have a
positive experience
it's going to hurt of course but if and
when you feel like it's all falling
apart
you feel terrible you should also know
that that isn't necessarily a predictor
of anything
because in a in a long race things
change you can feel terrible then you'll
feel good then you'll feel
terrible again and you learn to just
keep going
no matter what and with that to adapt to
any unforeseen variables that get thrown
in your direction
a lot of times athletes they visualize
they train
and they're very attached to the race
unfolding in a very specific way and the
minute
something goes wrong like you step in a
puddle and suddenly your foot's all wet
or
you know i don't know somebody bumps you
when you fall down anything
unforeseen can throw somebody off their
mental game
and and they have a hard time kind of
getting back into it so
i think a sort of understanding that
there's going to be
variables that get thrown in your way
and learning how to be resilient with
those
is super important and something to
prepare mentally and physically for in
your training
in addition on race day you should know
what your strategy is and you should
implement that meaning
run your race not the race that the
person next to you is running
it's very easy especially when there's a
lot of people around you and people are
passing you
that you can get caught up in what
others are doing and
it takes a certain level of of of
confidence and discipline to
not let any of that impact your plan
that you've set for yourself so sticking
to your plan is key
and that also means that on race day
you're going to have all this extra
energy you're going to be very excited
there's going to be a lot of
crowd and whatever and if you find
yourself feeling like
you're like five miles in and you feel
amazing a lot of athletes throw their
race plan out the window and just start
speeding up because they feel great only
to like
explode at mile 18. so if you feel
amazing
resist that urge to go faster and stick
to your plan
in terms of after race which i think is
really the
the core of what casey um wants
answers to um i think after your race
it's important to do an inventory of
what went right and what went wrong
you can write it out in a journal just
you know
in freehand like everything that that
you thought about every emotional
experience
what it felt like physically where it
went to plan where it didn't go to plan
you can mine the data and all of that is
um you know an ample opportunity to
learn from the experience that you
just had but the important thing is
in the aftermath of the race have fun
go to the beer garden whatever enjoy
yourself make sure you hydrate
fuel up stay warm you know ice your legs
i think active recovery in the days that
follow is super important if it's your
first marathon
you're going to be unbelievably stiff
and have trouble going up and down
stairs or even walking around but you've
gotta
you shouldn't just lay in bed you should
get up and and move and go on walks and
try to get the blood flowing in a in a
low-grade way
and that'll help flush out all the
lactic acid and help you recover
a little bit more quickly but there's no
need to go running for you know i don't
know
a week or 10 days or something like that
like allow your body to heal and i think
another mistake a lot of athletes make
is they want to get right back into it
too
quickly and they underestimate just how
much their body gets beat up in you know
running something like a marathon so
giving your body the space and the time
to repair itself
takes longer than you might imagine and
providing that opportunity for yourself
i think is important
go to the beer garden advice i never
thought i'd hear rich roll
deliver on i'm not going to be well i
can go to the beer garden i'm not going
to drink the beer but he can drink the
beer
yes that's what he wants to do um i
always
enter any sort of race with one plan
hmm just don't come in last
well what's wrong with that was wrong
coming in last yeah the lantern rouge
i'm sure as i age i will even let that
go
this is the extent of your competitive
fire the extent of my
ego egotism i would suggest
not even thinking about that at all
because that means that you're
gauging your performance off of other
people oh it's true
you should just think about executing
your race
the way that you train for
[Music]
you